if only there was this group of people
that were somehow better than us more
enlightened than us also richer than us
and if they could just meet say once a
year in a secret place and talk about
how we should live our lives well then
things would be much better and that is
quite literally happening so here is
video of the world economic forum's
Klaus Schwab Klaus Schwab who is right
at a Central Casting as an 80s
Schwarzenegger or Mel Gibson movie
villain uh here he is talking about all
the rich people who are about to get
together in Davos and talk about how you
should live your life
it is so exciting so that's the
beginning of the year we can meet again
in person
only personal interaction creates a
necessary level of trust which we need
so much in our fragmented and fractured
world
to bring people together
for an informal dialogue in a remote
Swiss Village such as Davos can be or
should be a good recipe to restore Trust
Central Casting 101 with this guy if you
were coming up with a bad guy to lead
the Elites in a movie that the action
hero was gonna have to bust in and take
care of business at the end it would be
Klaus Schwab so you see they make us
think that the weather is coming to kill
all of us they make us think that kovid
is coming to kill all of us
etc
etc and somehow they will meet in a
remote I like how he said it has to be
in a remote Village I mean we can't just
do this you know just where people are
hanging out they have to be in a remote
village where they will have an informal
dialogue yes it'll be very informal over
foie gras and champagne as they discuss
the policies that they will institute in
our governments as if they have any
control over our governments now they do
they should not but they do uh the guy's
evil the guy is absolutely evil
foreign
[Music]